- Welcome back to my one
on one with the First Lady.
We are on our way to meet Major and Champ,
well, I am, you've already met them.
(laughing)
But, we're walking through
the Dip Room right?
- Isn't it beautiful.
- Yeah, it's gorgeous.
Is the wallpaper, is it
Jackie Kennedy?
- Jackie Kennedy, yes.
- It's beautiful.
- Look how beautiful
that looks.
- I know, I know.
- And our fireplace.
- I know, so this is the
famous fireplace, right?
- Yes.
- That FDR,
- that he did all
his fireside chats.
Have you had any chats?
- Not really, no.
- You should do it.
Just have a girlfriend down
here, just say you did it.
- Well, you can come and do a chat.
- Okay, fine.
I am down for that.
I'm down for that.
All right, let's go see the dogs.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- Oh, well I.
- Here we go.
- This is Major.
- And Champ.
- This is Champ.
- Come over and say hello to them.
- Oh, I want to say hello.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my goodness!
- Hey, hey.
Say, go say hi to Kelly.
- Oh my goodness.
- Go ahead.
- Can you come say hi?
Oh, you are so special.
Is there anywhere that
they're not allowed to go?
- They're not allowed on the furniture,
but of course, Major,
I caught him on the couch the other day,
but he quickly jumped down, so.
- Yeah.
- But they, they run all
over which is so nice that.
- It's a beautiful lawn,
yeah.
- Yeah.
It's a beautiful lawn
and look at the view that we have.
- It's beautiful.
- And then if you look that way,
the Truman Balcony.
- It feels like I'm in a movie
right now.
- Yeah.
Well, I feel that way almost every day
and I cannot wait till
we can open it again
post pandemic so that
people can come through
and just see how special it really is.
- I heard also your Valentine's
Day was special here.
I loved, there were big
beautiful hearts on the lawn
that was.
- You know, the staff
they were so excited about it
and everybody came together and painted.
I mean, everybody had red
and pink and white paint
all over their hands.
- Yeah.
- That morning, I got up, I
felt like a kid at Christmas
and I woke Joe up and
I said, get up, get up,
come on, there's a Valentine surprise.
He's pulling on his pants.
He said, well, do I have to shave?
And I, and I said, no, just come on.
And I grabbed two cups of coffee
and out we went
and he loved it.
He really loved it.
- It's such a beautiful big, wait,
speaking of shaving, this
is one thing I love too,
that anytime you have an important message
for President Biden, you
put it right on the mirror
where he shaves.
- Yeah, I do.
- I love that.
Have you ever put,
remember you married up.
(laughing)
No, but I'll try, try that one.
- That would be my first one.
Well, I, I truly do,
I love how compassionate you are.
I love your heart.
I, I cannot just wait to
see what you're gonna do.
You're gonna do amazing things
as First Lady.
- Aw, thanks, Kelly.
- And you tweeted about my home state,
which was really important and cool,
you know, for me and, and people I love
that are really struggling right now.
So thank you for that.
- Oh, our hearts go out
to the people in Texas.
You know already they were
dealing with the pandemic
but then with this storm
- Yeah.
- and no water, no food, no heat.
- And Oklahoma national
- Yeah.
- there's so many places
right now affected it.
So I really appreciate it.
I mean, it means a lot.
And also just from one like incredibly,
you know nobody from a small town
to be able to just sit
across from the First Lady
and, you know talk with you
and just have a conversation.
Honestly, it sounds so cheesy,
but it is truly why I love this country
because you can dream incredibly big here
and actually make it happen.
And I just, it's a really
cool thing and it's special,
it's special to me and it was a privilege.
So thank you.
- Oh, thanks.
Well, just remember I,
I'm from a small town too
from outside Philadelphia.
- And look where you came,
that's what I'm saying.
This is a great country.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So the American dream is alive and well.
- Yeah.
- Well, thank you so much.
I love that we ended with my
favorite, my favorites here.
- Major,
come here, come on.
Are you gonna come here?
He's like, what, what
are all these people.
- Oh my God, he would love my Henry.
So next time I'll bring Henry.
You can say hi to him.
- Okay.
(laughing)
Come back, please come back.
- All right, thank you so much.
I, I really appreciate it, Dr. Biden.